you should start your experiment by
choosing what it is you want to focus on
for example do you want to improve
traffic or the number of signups do you
want to increase the number of people
who are actually buying your product or
service or do you want to increase the
sharing between people and social sites
once you choose what you want to focus
on you can start coming up with ideas on
what you can do to tweak it and actually
move that needle on those metrics that
you're interested in think about things
that would really make a difference so
Ronnie and I went to the drawing board
for a bark mitt to come up with a list
of ideas we decided to focus on
increasing conversions from people just
visiting our site to actually signing up
to use a barkman some of the ideas we
came up with word changing the text on
the landing page to explain a bark meant
differently changing the color and the
size of the sign up button trying a
different messaging and our emails
adding a video showcasing happy
customers highlighting a few positive
reviews on the landing page or even
designing a whole new landing page now
we need to narrow down our ideas to
three maybe four of the most important
ones that would make the biggest impact
we also want to think about which ones
we can actually implement easily and
what are some quick wins for example
designing a whole new landing page may
be harder than just moving the sign up
button to the top of the page next is
any scientist would you should create a
hypothesis and measure your baselines
you actually know if you're causing
change for your hypothesis think about
this if we do blank our blank will grow
by blank so for a barkman if we move the
sign up button to the top of the page
our conversions will grow by eight
percent now later on we can try the rest
of our ideas and experiment on those too
but we should test one thing at a time
so we can isolate the specific change
and move the needle that way for our
baseline we can look at our conversions
through google analytics before we make
the change to see what they are